getting fired from a project what did it
teach you whether you feel you were
wronged whether you feel you're right I
think it taught me that it's important
to stick to your guns when you know at a
base level go with your gut always go
with your guys a film anger there's
there's something inside you that says
you know this looks good or this looks
good but as a person there's something
inside you that says this is morally
wrong and I got fired because I didn't
want to do something that I felt was
morally wrong and that's because we were
filming this movie we were on day two of
filming and there was a sex scene with
that with the lead actor in the actors
horror movie and the the lead actress
asked for a closed set and so I say okay
only me the DP and the boom op and the
actors in the room everybody out and the
the producer goes that i paid
that to see her tits and i said
what and he said no I paid her
to see her tits she starts crying and
I'm like no you you got to go out and
he's like no and I'm like you can't I
can't this is day two of filming she's
the lead actress I can't get her to
trust me or believe in me or really
become vulnerable with me so I can tap
into you know her emotions for the
project if i wronged her on the second
day but also it's just I'm morally
against that that's wrong she wants
something I'm not going to put somebody
in a compromising situation and so he
says well it's my way or the highway and
I said well I guess it's the highway
then and he goes all right you're fired
and I was like okay I'm on a pay or play
contract though so give me my money and
so he gave me my money and I used that
money and made to Jennifer because not
only a did I realize that this movie was
never going to get made the one that he
fired me off of because what was he
going to do directed himself and
whatever
uh it ended up not well because also
when he fired me the crew really liked
me so they quit advice to other people
who are let go from a project whether
they're paid or not emotionally not just
like you know have a good lawyer okay
have a good lawyer but also emotionally
realize that it's important to be
amicable in any situation I pride myself
on being easy to get along with and so
if you pride yourself on being easy to
get along with and you're nice to
everybody and are really genuinely doing
the best job that you can and you get
fired from the project and it's their
loss not yours and you have to realize
that because at the end of the day that
guy's probably kicking himself because
the movie never got made and he should
have kept me on it and he shouldn't have
been such an but you have to
realize that if you're putting your best
foot forward and you're doing the best
you can then you were true to yourself
and don't be upset if people are against
that you have to stay true to yourself
and believe in yourself and believe that
what you're doing is right and if you
get fired for the wrong reasons like in
that situation I felt it was a
ridiculous situation but you stuck to
your guns for the right reasons then I'd
say okay did you have some down days
after that no I started filming to
Jennifer like two days later go out
there and make a movie on an iPhone 5
that's what I say
you